este vídeo contiene debates y
referencias sobre la cosa sexual y otros
temas delicados las personas en este
vídeo se hicieron la prueba para el cob
y 19
veamos te da miedo probar cosas anales
le pedimos a nuestra audiencia que
enviara a sus preguntas sexuales más
íntimas vergonzosas y picantes para que
extraños las respondieran basándose en
sus experiencias
educación sexual hombres heterosexuales
dinos qué tan seguido piensas en sexo
podría decir que pienso en eso un par de
veces al día una vez que tuviste sexo es
normal que piensas en ello eso creo no
lo hago a menudo pero puede pasar cuando
era virgen todas las horas del día todos
los días de la semana
después de eso quizá una vez al día
cuando perdiste tu virginidad de cómo
fue de hecho la pérdida en octubre del
2020 no fue como lo esperaba porque
vengo de una familia religiosa y pensaba
voy a esperar hasta que me casé pero no
más bien fue algo muy rápido de verdad
la perdí muy joven como los 14 y puedo
decir que no fue una de mis mejores
experiencias debo admitir que no fue lo
mejor por supuesto no sabía qué demonios
estaba haciendo creo que fue genial no
fue tan bueno como parece en el porno
pero tampoco estuvo mal durante mucho
tiempo incluso llegué a pensar que tenía
un caso muy muy leve de disfunción
eréctil o ocasional me causaba una gran
ansiedad todo lo relacionado con el sexo
así que cada vez que tenía una
oportunidad de tener sexo sucedía que mi
cuerpo no quería lo mismo que yo hay una
persona en particular a la que nunca
olvidaré ella estaba tumbada en la cama
y me dijo vaya tienes una mujer desnuda
frente a ti y no tienes una erección y
ya saben eso fue como una avalancha de
todos esos esos sentimientos de
incompetencia y todo lo negativo que
imaginé que podría pasar en mi vida
sexual si eso pasó en ese momento te
vinculas emocionalmente con las chicas
con las que tienes sexo para mí se basa
más en las relaciones que podemos
construir que en la cantidad de sexo que
tenemos es difícil para mí tener sexo
sin sentimientos siempre termino
extrañando a esa persona al final yo me
tardé un poco más no hice nada en la
secundaria pero cuando termine la
secundaria comencé en la universidad las
chicas comenzaron a interesarse en mí
así que no podían importarme menos los
sentimientos con cualquier chica que que
me gustara un poco solo pensaba genial
asombroso entienden tal vez eres una
persona rible pero o bien lo
resolveremos luego estoy feliz de estar
aquí
que tanto sabes de la anatomía sexual
femenina y abajo puedes nombrar todas
las partes ahora mismo hay partes no es
sólo una cosa no soy un científico ni me
especializo en anatomía no debería
intentarlo vagina buen comienzo en bien
es decir es solo la vagina cierto no es
así pues conozco el clítoris bueno el
clítoris no sé lo que es el clítoris
algo grande y algo pequeño a labios no
creo que se llaman labios no creo que
sea el nombre real o si podría ser una
tontería pero la uretra
y el capuchón cierto creo que lo leí en
alguna parte vulva es esto es decir
cuántas cosas pueden haber ahí abajo
como lo hice genial idea ver vídeos de
youtube después puedes describir lo que
se siente al eyacular se siente como
orinar diría que la única vez que se
siente como orinar es cuando ya has
aguantado durante mucho tiempo y estás
tratando de ir al baño y entonces te
relajas y dices no no sé es cómo una
anticipación y luego es como es como una
bola que solo
entienden pero después lo ves y te da
asco la mayoría de las veces lo he
escuchado muchos chicos sólo dicen una
vez que lo ves te da asco te importa que
las chicas estén totalmente depiladas no
creo tener autoridad para decirles algo
como oyen sabes algo podrías depilarte
por mí creo que sería extraño soy un
gran fan de las vaginas en general sin
importar el aspecto me gustan
prefiero que estén depiladas pero como
sea está bien si mientras estén limpias
por supuesto te importa si tu pareja no
acaba si a todo el mundo debería
importarle dios mío todo esto es la
doble moral me frustra demasiado me
siento culpable si no lo hago cuando se
trata de sexo una parte de tu placer
proviene de sentir el placer de la otra
persona si estoy con ella es decir si
estamos saliendo soy la parte sexual eso
es lo primero y mi lista ella debe
acabar si es una aventura pues no para
ser honesto no me importa saben me
preocuparía más por mi placer no voy a
mentir cuando se trata de aventuras
puedo ser un poco egoísta
pero si estamos saliendo de verdad me
preocupo mucho por eso cuando estaba en
una una relación larga y seria creo que
ella nunca tuvo un orgasmo no conmigo al
menos así que durante ese tiempo me
esforcé mucho estuve leyendo muchas
cosas para ver que podía hacer para que
eso sucediera pero eso nunca sucedió y
eso fue un gran golpe para luego pensé
viejo me pregunto qué se siente porque
yo nunca es decir nunca lo experimentado
para ser honesto
alguna vez has cuestionado a tu
sexualidad por supuesto totalmente
durante mucho tiempo la gente en la
calle asumía que yo era gay etcétera y
durante mucho tiempo odie esa suposición
pero al final decidí tomarme el tiempo
para preguntarme oye qué pasa si es así
y es por eso que hice lo que debía e
intente ser honesto conmigo mismo para
reconocer cómo era y que me interesaba o
no
y al final creo que llegué a una
conclusión definitiva en definitiva me
gustan las páginas es así super muy
pronto que me gustaban las mujeres
tuve tuve mi primera novia cuando bueno
mi primera novia cuando estaba en el
primer creado tuve mi primer beso con
una niña cuando estaba en tercero sino
nunca fue algo que cuestione sí pues yo
yo tengo raíces mexicanas y pues saben
que los latinos suelen ser muy varoniles
y se te exige ser esto o lo otro y cosas
así cualquier cosa que no implicara ser
el típico macho o lo que eso signifique
no era bien visto para nada que sea un
hombre o dos
creo que ese es talvez el alcance de mi
experimentación he pensado en eso
tal vez una o dos veces viví en el medio
oeste toda mi vida y todo el mundo ahí
es bastante conservador así que al
crecer con esas creencias lo más ideal
es que me gustaran las mujeres en su
mayoría fue un pensamiento pasajero en
algún momento lo pensé sobre todo
después de mudarme de casa pero nunca
llegué a sentir esa conexión genuina con
otro hombre así que nunca hice nada al
respecto
alguna vez te has sentido acomplejado
por el tamaño de tu pene
no respuesta corta la respuesta directa
sería que sí porque hay un estereotipo
muy desagradable acerca de las personas
de mi raza y no digo que sea cierto o
falso porque es algo que se mete en tu
cabeza aunque sea un poco porque es
decir no se sabe si es real o no así que
es normal que cuando me veo desnudo me
preguntes bien
esto es normal no lo es no lo sé en
especial como un afroamericano
hay un montón de expectativas que son
muy muy muy muy elevadas esperas que
tengas un pene muy grande
así que te das cuenta de que no tienes
un pene muy grande así que durante mucho
tiempo creo que gran creo que gran parte
de mi ansiedad se debía que yo me sentía
un fracaso
y que no cumplía con las expectativas de
los demás es algo que recibe mucha
atención cuando vas a la tienda y
compras un paquete de calzoncillos o
algo así siempre fueras a algún tipo muy
tonificado y que compra las tallas más
grandes del lugar y dices qué demonios
así es como se supone que debemos lucir
cuando entras en la secundaria empiezas
a ver porno y ves a todos estos actores
que están en las películas y son así que
solo puedes pensar en no puedes competir
con eso solo mírame te da miedo a probar
probar cosas anales no quiero que nadie
se acerque a mi trasero
jajajajaja
creo que si me lo hicieran a mí sí
tendrían vida de trabajar y creo creo
que tendría miedo incluso si yo si yo
soy quien lo hago no lo sé ha escuchado
historias muy malas no lo sé me pone
nerviosa
si me pone un poco nervioso pero creo
que tengo que probar en algún momento
estoy abierto a las posibilidades
creencia al entrar por esa puerta me
hubieran dicho que tendría una
oportunidad de tener sexo anal
probablemente me habría negado y ni
siquiera ni siquiera sé si puedo decir
el porqué porque yo no sé que no soy gay
no es una cuestión de mi sexualidad no
diría que tengo miedo
podrían convencerme si podría
convencerme en el lugar en el momento
adecuados podría decir que si tuvo la
oportunidad de hacerlo una vez y solo
para evitar la doble moral lo probé y no
es para mí dios mío no si lo probé y no
me gustó de hecho de hecho fue la
primera vez que tuve sexo sentí su dedo
entrar ahí como y entonces sólo pensé oh
vaya lo probé y no me gustó pero si les
gusta eso muy bien está bien
muy bien cómo defines el consentimiento
para mí el consentimiento es que ambas
partes estén de acuerdo en hacer algo
con lo que ambos se sientan cómodos
me gusta preguntar te sientes cómoda con
esto o aquello y si eso es un sí
estupendo pero si es lo contrario
entonces usamos una palabra de seguridad
como banana o algo así y significa que
hay que parar el consentimiento es un
deseo inequívoco que se da en el momento
de participar en cualquier actividad
específica con otra persona incluyendo
el sexo o cosas que no se relacionan con
él tus parejas sexuales te han pedido
algunas veces tu consentimiento
no para nada qué demonios me gustaría
que eso existiera sería genial no
normalmente soy yo el que en el que
pregunta pero está bien sí y cuando pasó
me sorprendí mucho pensé guau realmente
lo importa y le dije si quiero tener
sexo gracias por preguntar más
presionado a alguien para que se cuente
contigo te arrepientes no en absoluto y
me arrepentiría si nunca ha hecho eso se
siente horrible así que no nunca lo he
hecho para mí el sexo no es tan
importante como para hacer eso y eso es
algo que que la otra persona tendría que
llevar consigo el resto de su vida y yo
también tendría que lidiar con eso de
repente estaba con mi novia y yo quería
hacerlo pero ella no así que intentaba
hablarle lindo para convencerla o cosas
así
solo eso pero nunca lo haría con una
desconocida nunca con alguien con quien
no tengo confianza suficiente solo con
mi novia o alguien con que me sintiera
muy cómodo por supuesto
y si admito que si lo hice
cuando era más joven si me arrepiento y
mucho porque ahora veo el sexo como algo
más especial y no deberíamos ir por ahí
y acostarnos con todo el mundo
debería ser con alguien que sea especial
para ti a mí si alguna vez tienes que
convencer a alguien por sexo entonces no
vale la pena
definitivamente me sentí presionado por
mis amigos pero asumo la responsabilidad
de mis actos lo hago tengo el control de
todo mi cuerpo y fue mi decisión mesa si
alguna vez has hecho algo que no querías
en el ámbito sexual
así
y creo que eso lo deje muy claro la
chica le dije no yo no quiero hacerlo no
quiero hacer esto solo suéltame y ya
así que si voy a responder sin rodeos
te has sentido presionado por tus amigos
para perder tu virginidad o tener
interacción sexual sí diría que sentí la
expresión de la sociedad y la cultura
porque el sexo es algo muy importante
especialmente para los jóvenes estaba en
una fraternidad en la universidad en mi
primer semestre era el único chico
virgen allí era todo un evento cada
viernes sábado cada vez que tenemos una
fiesta
era lo único en lo que podía pensar ni
siquiera podía pensar en la escuela la
mayor parte del tiempo porque todo lo
que pensaba era que quería quitarme esa
etiqueta de una vez estaba harto hay un
gran estigma sobre ser virgen y de
verdad no deberíamos sentirnos mal por
ser vírgenes para ser honesto para ser
muy honesto yo a veces lo hago amigo
estás obligado a tener sexo con la chica
o si no te consideran un gran perdedor
viejo yo solo pienso bien pero qué pasa
si realmente me gusta la chica y no
quiero tener sexo todavía no quiero ir
tan rápido sabes ya pasará solo relájese
está claro que tienen ganas está bien
pasará cuando tenga que pasar solo no se
sienten presionados es diferente para
todos y al final del día nos tomaremos
el tiempo para entendernos y ser
honestos con nosotros mismos
suscríbase a billy para más educación
sexual
ah